dans l'enceinte de la mairie les groupes
se prépare les enfants d'un côté
maquillage costumes répétitions de danse
les adultes également avec les travestis
aux premières loges
ça donne ça donne notre ali monté comme
un bon moment s'habille phrase je n'ai
fait que morizet début des mondiaux le
père du carnaval ivoire aux antilles et
c'est lui georges raboteur ce
martiniquais installés en côte d'ivoire
depuis 2005 organise cette année son
septième carnaval ici il ya huit ans de
cela
au début nous étions à peu près 100 et
quelques personnes la deuxième année
avait 300 à peu près et ensuite quand on
est arrivé à plusieurs vies nous sommes
arrivés déjà à 2000 3000 personnes de
tout ici ce qui attendait pas du tout et
la dernière année on a eu vingt cinq
mille personnes
[Musique]
la grande nouveauté cette année c'est la
venue d'une délégation de la martinique
conduite par le député jean-philippe ni
lors une quinzaine de carnavaliers au
nombre desquels le tanbouyé sur lesquels
j
du fait des master classes pour
expliquer le bel le damier avec les
écoles l'école de musique qui est ici et
je continue aussi il ya beaucoup de
questions du monde me reposer et sur le
carnaval de certitudes quant à valls et
c'est le moment où le peuple heures le
pub système le moment où le mexique 3-1
du graphiste du ve et de défoulement et
je suis content d'être là pour me
défouler avec tous les tous les amis de
la côte d'ivoire
[Musique]
pour les martiniquais la fête a commencé
la veille avec l'accueil en grande pompe
à l'ouverture des festivités
carnavalesques trois ministres et une
vingtaine de chefs coutumiers pour leur
souhaiter la bienvenue
notre voyage
aujourd'hui en côte d'ivoire des titres
est symbolique c'est tout autre jour sur
la terre mère une fois de plus le
carnaval rassemble les peuples
alors que la fête ne faisait que
commencer cet après-midi les
martiniquais songer déjà revenir l'an
prochain encore plus nombreux encore
plus nombreux à dévaler ce boulevard qui
sévit dès ce soir